uh we got the story from the
Philadelphia Inquirer yes Wawa's
decision to close two stores is a dire
statement about Public Safety in
Philadelphia despite assertions at the
contrary the move by the locally based
convenience store chain speaks volumes
about the state of crime in the city
I'll just give you my personal story in
the state of crime in the city we didn't
live in Philly we live just just across
the bridge we're in we're in South
Jersey
five minutes away from the bridge when
the riots happened and what they call
the summer of love the 529 Insurrection
I thought we were fine I'm like well
we're not in Philly we got we got the
river there's people are gonna no I
heard the helicopters I heard the sirens
the the the Riders crossed the bridge
all of a sudden now I'm sitting here
thinking
I'm not going to sit around here and
wait for this kind of this level of
violence and this crime so we decided to
leave we came down to the the tri-state
area here West Virginia Harper's Ferry
and since then what we've seen out of
Philadelphia has been horrifying I mean
as soon as we got out we saw the story
of the guy holed up in his house
shooting at cops we're hearing uh just I
mean you had the the wall where everyone
went in and started ransacking
everything now Wawa is leaving we see
this in Portland too they just shut down
I think the Pearl District Starbucks
because of crime not that it was only a
few months ago they announced 16 other
stores nationwide be shutting down
because crime is skyrocketing so so
what's going on man why is why is crime
through the roof what can you do about
it what can we do about it it's funny
crime comes up a lot in the federal
Senate races but there's nothing a
federal Senator can do at the state
level for crime in exactly and so it's a
bit disingenuous they talk about you
know they're going to bring in a Law and
Order back it's like dude
constitutionally how do you do that
exactly but a governor has a lot to say
about it the irony is of course my
opponent is the attorney general he's
been in that job for six years and he's
got one job enforcing Law and Order and
he's failed on his watch you know John
Adams said facts are stubborn things and
so let me just give you some facts I
don't do I'm not a politician I don't do
sound bites like that but the fact is
crime has gone up nearly 40 on his watch
Statewide Statewide wow where the fourth
highest in fentanyl death so Robbie and
I were there in in Kensington a couple
weeks ago I'll have rev describe what
our experience there
um homicides we're looking at on track
for about 600 this year it's about 430
as of today a thousand carjackings 4 400
robberies a couple thousand shootings uh
the gravediggers in Philadelphia said
they can't keep up burying the dead
teenagers and uh you know my my opponent
can't run on this record and sadly thank
God for you know that we have alternate
Outlets like you guys because the
traditional media covers for them
because if that was a republican they'd
be breathless reporting on how you know
this this person had failed the people
of the state you know and turned his
backs on instead of doing his job and
trying to protect the people we saw the
you know the Mayhem in the in the
Mayfair District that's crazy we saw the
shooting after football game in Roxboro
another safe area of Philly we saw a
carjacking outside in Chester County
outside of Philly of a mom and a
daughter going to school and being you
know a carjack to you know seven o'clock
in the morning oh yeah yeah I saw that
yeah I mean it's heartbreaking real
people are suffering and so what can I
do about it and uh number one we're
going to become a law and order State
because Shapiro is part of the defund
the police group he's friends with BLM
and antifa so they'll know that their
governor has their back and then
secondly be working with the general
assembly to make sure they're fully
funded we'll expand a number of police
we have on the on the ground we'll need
we need more the people in Kensington in
Philadelphia are asking for more
presents and then finally
I'll be surging special prosecutors in
the Philly with the authorization of the
House and Senate because there are
Constitutional Powers Josh Shapiro was
given that authorization and he refused
to use it and instead of putting
criminals in jail he's worked with the
wolf Administration to release release
about 10 000. I know fetterman's getting
hit on the head a lot about how he's
released you know voted to release in
the parole board you know all these
murders what have you Josh Shapiro was
also on that board yeah look it's one
thing uh there was a tweet I saw it was
Tim Ryan saying he wants to reduce the
prison population in Ohio immediately
this is knee-jerk reaction from a lot of
people on the right saying like wow
that's a devastating in bed but the
first thing he says is he wants to get
marijuana off the schedule and that's
that's a there's a there's a big
difference between people who are in
jail for non-violent drug offenses and
people who are convicted of murder the
thing about fetterman is that many of
the people he's actually talked about
getting out are people who are convicted
of murder granted he says oh it was a
wrong conviction or it was you know
wrong for this reason or that reason or
their protests okay well that is you
talking about people who are convicted
of murder and I and I fully respect if
someone's in you know prison and they're
innocent and you can prove it they
should be released it should never
happen like that but it's not the same
as you know for fetterman If he if he
wants to come out and say non-violent
drug offenses should not be handled this
way then I'm like okay all right right
on key distinction right the problem is
you look at New York and there's other
places and they're letting out violent
offenders there was a there was a story
about a guy who had like committed like
40 robberies laughing saying you keep
letting me out and I keep doing it
that's that's the problem you agree yeah
there's an important distinction to make
here because personally I'm for Criminal
Justice Reform especially when it comes
to victimless crimes but at the same
time what they're doing is absolutely
absurd it's absolutely crazy it's almost
as if they really deliberately want to
make the situation as unbearable and as
bad as possible on the streets and you
see a huge rise in crime specifically
where George Soros has invest invested
into the attorney generals into the
district attorneys and uh correct me if
I'm wrong but but it looks like Shapiro
got two donations uh for his campaigns
twice from George Soros and has been
supported by him that is a fact and so
we're in Kensington and so that's the
only open-air drug Market in America and
you want to share yourself a lot more in
San Francisco and New York City now
that's the biggest one in America and it
was heartbreaking because honestly that
for the people that are trying to live
there and just be safe and raise a
family there is no safe place you know
even in their homes their shootings and
the bullets go in and the kids um one
grandmother raising five kids by herself
said they know the difference between a
firecracker and a gunshot you know and
they know what to do they know to run
upstairs and lay flat on the floor and I
think the youngest one's like five years
old the other thing is the school's just
locked down because of some sort of
crime and the parents aren't told why
the school's locked down so now your
kids you know are locked in and not able
to come home but you don't know if it's
an internal or an extra you don't know
what the problem is and so there's just
a lot of fear that it's instilling into
the parents because they don't know
every day if their kids are gonna what
happens when a school gets locked down
like how long is a lockdown for I think
various times from what she was telling
us we we talked of different people when
we were down there but her story was is
it just keeps happening it's something
that's almost weekly and it varies you
know it might just be you know for an
hour because they heard there was
something in the vicinity and so they
were trying to keep the kids in before
they let them out you know to to head
home but you know sometimes it's
internal and if that's the case I don't
know how long that might be might be for
hours what I don't get is that when this
kind of stuff happens the only thing I
hear from your modern liberal or leftist
is it's the guns that's the problem and
I'm like well it's crime it's criminals
you know uh Pennsylvania is pretty good
on gun laws I'm told is that is that is
that true
yeah I mean it's I didn't live there
most of the state obviously is is
strongly advocating for Second Amendment
um you know there's one of the most
restrictive cities uh you know in a
nation is Philadelphia it hasn't done
them very good but it's my understanding
is it's still not nearly as restrictive
restrictive as all of New Jersey because
you know I'm living in the Jersey side
and there that's absolutely true they're
giving you warnings but I bring this up
because this means that you know I heard
a story about people in Philadelphia and
they're armed and everything's fine they
go to Jersey and also they're getting
arrested and I'm like wait regular
law-abiding citizens are armed in
Philadelphia well yeah if you're pulled
over you got a Pennsylvania plate don't
answer any questions in Jersey if you
have a weapon on you but but I mean uh I
play the fifth the issue clearly is not
the guns or the gun owners right the
area the issue is clearly the criminals
and you know it's one of the reasons I
didn't want to be in New Jersey because
of how insane the laws were I was told
that if someone look I'm fi I was five
minutes from the bridge we would drive
five minutes and you could see
Philadelphia you look out the window and
you can see the buildings and everything
and I was told in Jersey that if someone
broke into my house I had a duty to
retreat from my own home in Jersey and
I'm like what is nuts where do you
Retreat to thank you I'm like do I jump
out the window and run Barefoot my
boxers down the street yes because they
were like is is that better than killing
someone and I'm like dude if someone's
threatening my life I could be out in
the winter and my bear that's the nuts
so I'm I look at you know Philadelphia
and I'm told the laws are better so we
do have the castle doctrine in
Pennsylvania of course what you know you
can only open fire and engage you know a
villain a potential perpetrator when
they're in your house that's when the
laws are completing in your hands just
really quickly if you oh sorry go ahead
on the porch is that in the house you
got to make sure it's far enough in that
if the gunshot throws them back they're
not out right so with their hands if
they're if their hands on the door the
doors cracked open that's not enough
they have to begin all the way in where
where was that uh story where the the
Angry ex-boyfriend do you see this one
tried banging on the door and tried
breaking the door open and the dad shot
through the door oh yes that that wasn't
Pennsylvania was it I think it was I
don't think so I I don't remember that
story specifically but but if you're a
governor how would you approach the
Second Amendment what action would you
take on it well obviously will be become
a section a second amendment Sanctuary
State I'll be signing into law some of
the bills I actually have in thank you I
like that yeah and so I'll be signing
into law I don't know if I'll go as far
as nukes but clearly not
get specific uh would you be okay for
constitutional carry yeah absolutely and
actually I'm a co-sponsor of that bill
in the Senate great awesome we're
constitutional care in West Virginia
it's fantastic it needs to be that way
and I don't even get why we have a
second amendment rate and I have to pay
25 bucks to get a license every couple
years it's like are you kidding me
additionally I have a bill and I'm a
prime sponsor of an incentive and I hope
the sign of the law when I'm Governor I
will actually where it will prohibit law
enforcement within Pennsylvania from
cooperating with the federals if Joe
Biden comes in to enforce to enforce
unconstitutional laws on the side nice
man yeah so the nuclear weapons thing is
uh it's more of a cultural Point using
something that's that's relatively
shocking first uh yeah private companies
private entities can have nukes I mean
you you've got major uh weapons
manufacturers that fill out the forms I
forgot what it's called we talked to a
guy who had an FFL and he explained as a
form for nuclear weapons and uh when the
second amendment was written you could
have a a frigate you could have a man of
war you could have a private warship and
you could actually contract with the
government that's what we have today
with these with private military
contractors and weapons manufacturers so
I think if people are concerned about a
private citizen getting access to
biological and nuclear weapons instead
of just deciding one day that the
Constitution doesn't matter we should
actually say okay well let's amend the
Constitution as we were supposed to do
it's more of a point that over a long
enough period of time people seem okay
with the fact that the constitution has
been eroded
that's the whole point of I think that's
probably the most important thing that
I've heard today is that we're seeing
infringements on our rights through uh
you know a thousand little Cuts here and
there and instead of doing the right
thing and saying okay do you have a
second Amendment right or not and and
approaching it from a constitutional
amendment process it's being
circumvented by by laws and by
bureaucrats and bureaucracy and what
have you additionally another piece of
legislation I'll be signing law of
course is reciprocity recognizing
people's right from other states coming
through that's amazing I'm glad to hear
it I love the Constitutional carry stuff
it's too easy it's very clear to me I
mean so we know what the US Constitution
says you know should not be infringed in
Pennsylvania Constitution says uh that's
your right to keep and bear arms shall
not be questioned wow really yes that's
beautiful yeah law-abiding citizens
shouldn't be treated like criminals it's
a simple it's a simple idea but so so
constitutional carry but let's let's get
a little into the nitty-gritty I guess
what about limitations on you know
magazine size or you know if you're
saying it's a sanctuary State I mean how
does that apply to say the NF fa like
selective fire rifles fully automatic
weapons yeah I mean honestly I haven't
gone that far but I am troubled by the
by the limitations because we even seen
Joe Biden talk about handguns you know
and having more than six rounds that
would even revolve right he doesn't even
know what he's talking about yeah
seriously there's a that it's that it's
illegal that you could be arrested in
New Jersey because you have a 30 round
magazine are you kidding me I mean
really I mean most most veterans have
some of those left over from the M16
days I mean and not just that there was
a viral video where it was in Italy I
think some they're only you're only
allowed to have three rounds and this
individualist woman I think one I think
it was a woman got attacked by a boar
and then fired three times and the board
did not stop and so people like this is
why but you look at what happened
someone tweeted you know what am I
supposed to do in 30 to 50 feral Hogs
come into my you know my yard and then
all of the liberal anti-gun people are
laughing as if it's not a real problem
and it is they don't understand you know
people getting helicopters and fly
around having to call the boar
population because they're dangerous and
they destroy the environment but these
people don't understand that they live
in New York where there is no boar
problem and then vote for you to be
hobbled when you do have a boar problem
you know it's it's nice when you're
living in a you know in a little bubble
somewhere you know and you know safe and
cozy and you have good Wi-Fi and you
know good transportation and you have a
private jet and the rest of us so if
it's kind of you mentioned a boar and we
lived in Germany for 10 years and so I
was out with our son and a couple of his
friends when they're little kids and
it's an Old Quarry in Germany and all of
a sudden it's this this boar came
jumping off of the top of the Quarry and
bounded off the walls and came straight
for us and all the kids were running and
I'm like what do you do and so I stepped
on a rock and stared at it and it lifted
it now looked me in the eyes and then
veered away it worked they said stare
the animal down and he veered right in
front of me and did they make your
shoulders big or anything
I'm just naturally yeah how tall are you
are you yeah but I was standing on a
rock because I hopped on a rock so he
didn't increased my height and he did
Veer away do you think there's value to
having different gun laws in cities and
in rural areas or do you just kind of
keep it I don't I do believe that the
second amendment should be consistent
across whether you're you know City or
rural
um you know the lawlessness lawlessness
in Philly I mean if that mom had a had a
sidearm with her and a carjacker came
and she could have put him out of his
misery instead of being terrorized and
what have you I honestly think there
wouldn't be a carjacking because people
would be like I better not even try
because then This Woman's probably I
remember in the 70s I had an aunt that
lived in Florida and we go visit her
down in Vero Beach and we were told
don't beep at people back then because
they might just shoot you so yeah an
armed Society is a polite society and we
have to understand it's basically right
you respect other people you don't freak
out you don't you don't you don't curse
the people you don't try to attack
people you don't try to steal their
stuff or violate their rights and as
long as you do that you'll be fine but
but again we also have to understand the
criminals we'll always find guns they
will always have you know things like
machine guns they will always have 30
round magazines and if the general
public is limited to like let's say five
rounds right a criminal knows that when
he's robbing the store oh the clerk only
has five rounds so if I'm in a shootout
with him one shot two shot three shot
four shot five shot he has to reload my
turn to get him now and it puts the
average citizen at a disadvantage when
criminals who don't follow the law
anyway will violate it and of course
will use it in order to justify the
punishment against the average
law-abiding human being I I'm not even
I'm I'm just tired of even hearing it
and saying it because it is it is basic
arithmetic it is it is so rudimentary it
is one plus one equals two if citizens
can't have guns and criminals are
already breaking the law you're
basically just saying the people who
don't care about the law can carry
weapons it's just one plus one equals
two and everybody listening to the show
knows it everybody at this table knows
it and we keep saying it but it doesn't
resonate with these people who are
trying to ban guns that the people only
only law-abiding people are going to pay
attention to those laws I just how do
you solve this in the bottom line do we
have a Second Amendment right or not and
if we don't then then do a
constitutional convention and not come
here and slowly strip away these rights
here and there because you're right when
you when you take the weapons away from
the from the innocent from the citizens
of course that then only the criminals
will be harmed and we've seen that over
and over again you look at Chicago I
mean I'm from Chicago the Wild Wild West
man and this is why I always tell my
friends who aren't from the city why you
don't get involved in Road road rage
incidents why like I'll be driving with
a friend and someone will cut them off
and start wailing on the horn and
flipping them off and I'll be like you
want to die because you never know if
who you're flipping off is going to be
some gang banger who's who's you know
looking for trouble it's a city where
the criminals the people who are intent
on committing crimes or who outright
just don't care about the law are the
ones who are armed you never know so
it's funny an armed Society is a polite
Society well in that respect in Chicago
don't pick fights unless as you know for
sure like don't pick fights you know
outright and then don't get into a fight
even if it's unless you you know your
circumstances so I mean what I mean by
that is if someone is getting up in your
face and they're threatening you the
fight the the fight you've always won is
the fight you've avoided is the saying
Chicago's a place where I've seen people
get into fights that it's just like you
want to talk smack about me you know put
up your dukes and I got okay and pulls
out a gun and that and they're going to
be criminals and the other issue is if
they have a gun these people are more
likely to to hurt you with it as opposed
to your law-abiding citizen who does not
want that fight so that's why I've you
know especially growing up in Chicago
I've just been like
we we'd be better off if the people were
scared to come near me to commit a crime
because I'd be armed because I'm telling
you all the criminals are armed as it is
they make videos of themselves waving
the guns around and all we can do is
cower and cross our fingers and hope
they're not going to shoot us
that's how crazy it gets for the most
part you don't got to worry about
getting shot in Chicago a lot of people
seem to think that because it's really
bad you're like walking on the street
motor flying everywhere I'll tell you
how bad it is it's um south side of
Chicago going to bed and hearing
gunshots it's getting a call from your
friend and saying I'm seeing some guy
drag a body down the alley those things
those things actually happened in my
life it's getting off of 290 on
Independence and then someone driving
past and just pointing a Gun and
shooting at my car for no reason that's
what Chicago is like but those are a
handful of incidents in the 20 plus
years when I before I finally moved out
so you know some people have this idea
that you go to Chicago and then every
day you're gonna be getting shot at no
but should you ever you're not going to
be happy about it right so something's
got to change thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there